voilà ma voix est en train de refaire le
même film que qu'en 2003 il y avait en
2003 le saccage du système de santé a
commencé 600 millions de courbe les
phares l'attend augmente c'était la même
chose la tête lorsqu'elle était ministre
le centre le résultat c'est que nos
services aux aînés dans les faits sont
moins de la qualité car vendre et que le
personnel n'en peut plus le taux de
détresse du personnel il a vraiment
élevé d'hommes d'armes loi vous décrivez
une situation qu'a provoqué entre autres
le gouvernement précédent et que nous
sommes à corriger et quand on connaît le
dr hébert qui est un spécialiste des
questions qui concernent les personnes
âgées
jamais je peux vous dire il
n'accepterait que l'on traitait
personnes âgées comme vous le décrivez